[Musica]
prima di raccontarvi la mia storia
voglio mostrarvi una popolazione di
cucina molto particolare qui abbiamo il
nostro prodotto
andiamo a lavorarlo togliendo prima i
semi
la buccia
e anche la crosta otteniamo il cuore che
è pronto per essere utilizzato
lo so sembrerà strano quello che ho
appena fatto non vi assicuro che sono
gesti quotidiani che tutti gli facciamo
quante volte sbucciamo la mela sbucciata
buttiamo di semi anche il picciolo
magari pacchettino ammaccate che sono
assolutamente commestibili
eppure non avete la stessa direzione che
detenuta adesso che tende di smontare un
vero da stiro e il mio sogno proprio
questo a scattare in tutti voi proprio
queste reazioni sono franca ripete ho 35
anni e sono un cuoco
sono profondamente colpito tutto quello
che sta accadendo sul nostro pianeta a
partire dal cambiamento del clima dalla
distruzione della biodiversità
dell'azzeramento quasi totale degli
ambienti selvaggi questo mi preoccupa
l'unico modo per sensibilizzare le
persone che mi ci cono e attraverso la
mia passione è ciò che ama cucinare
sono nato a scafati in una piccola
periferia in provincia di salerno
il ricordo benissimo la mia infanzia
quando girovagavano con la bici mi
perdevo spesso mercanti curiosavo per
cercare nuovi getti nove piante
addirittura cercava la merenda
direttamente dalla melo è proprio in
questo momento che ho imparato uno dei
video i mestieri anche se in modo
giocoso quello del contadino questo è
permesso fin da piccolo rapporto con il
cibo di amore e non solo ma anche di
grande consapevolezza di tutta la fatica
che c'è dietro e del rispetto del nostro
ambiente
ricordo benissimo anche le domeniche
passate in casa impastando cento
marmellate facendo pesanti ed è stato lì
che mi sono veramente appassionati
quando da adulto sono diventato cuoco
tutto quello che ho imparato si è
rafforzata attraverso le esperienze ed è
diventata la mia cucina
non solo anche il mio stile di vita ed
ecco alcuni piatti che mi rappresentano
cos'hanno di speciale questi piatti
della mia cucina sono realizzati tutti
compatti che la maggior parte di voi che
mi regolo scatti e che fosse
punterebbero e che per me sono invece il
valore aggiunto che li rende unici
prendiamo un esempio questo broccolo
sapete quanto ne scattiamo il 50 per
cento perché tutti siamo abituati a
utilizzare solamente lecce mente quando
il bianco è assolutamente ricco di fibre
di vitamine e perché lo buttiamo fossero
i pregiudizi e paure
vi voglio mostrare come diventerebbe il
gambo
aggiungiamo un'estrazione di prezzemolo
amministrazioni di carota
ieri infine di zucca
iniziamo a guardare al cibo sotto una
luce nuova
riprendiamoci i nostri tempi e
stupiamoci ancora di nuovo su come una
parte così poco nobile che consideriamo
così poco nobile che lo scarto possa
sorprenderci e vendere il catto unico
cuciniamo in modo nuovo dove il nulla
assolutamente sprecato
questo non vuole essere l'ennesimo
consiglio da scelta ma bensì la
richiesta di una persona che crede
ancora che tutti insieme possiamo
salvare il nostro pianeta perché
produrre meno scarti vuol dire anche
produrre meno rifiuti meno cibo meno co2
e soprattutto salvaguardare nei nostri
risorse naturali sono il nostro futuro e
quindi come la natura insegna bisogna
essere però tutti connessi